you as a republican who do you want
running to give you the highest chance
of winning do you want it to be Biden or
do you think Newsom stands a better
chance no I think you're looking tall
well spoken goes to French Laundry
frightening you know
I think I think Newsom would be it's
hard to see this is so ridiculous
analyzing who's easy to beat because
usually the person you think is easier
to beat is the person who beat you
the examples like uh Reagan and Trump
and probably others that I can think of
uh
right now I would I would I'd worry
about Biden because it's so damn corrupt
and um
for some reason I mean he's unpopular
his unpopularity is up around 56 57 it
should be about 65 I mean he
there's still kind of an affection for
him that's scary I mean he is a terrible
president but let's put everything aside
the sand is Trump everything is hot
he probably is definitely the worst
president in my lifetime
uh he may be the worst president ever
I'm trying to think of a president to
hurt this country more than him in a
short period of time
got people killed because of his
incompetence like Afghanistan those
people would accomplish wouldn't have
just been Trump who would have said no
to taking out the troops uh before this
almost any sane person would do that how
about leaving uh 45 billion dollars
worth of lethal arms behind at Pegram
air base in a country dominated by
terrorists who you know are going to use
them to kill your kill your own people
which they have done
that that decision can only be made by a
traitor or a Madman
I mean the guy has been a terrible
president
but there is something Mr Giuliani no
but there's some people there's
something scary about him and being able
the American people don't register that
they watch them uh three weeks ago four
weeks ago he told the story about giving
his uncle the Congressional Medal of
Honor
uh his uncle didn't want it
uh and his father told him at his
inauguration his vice president that his
uncle had never gotten his medal so he
organized a big ceremony in the White
House and gave him the medal now here
are the facts his uncle never got the
Congressional Medal of Honor there's no
evidence of it anywhere his uncle was
dead for five years
before he was in the White House and his
father was dead for seven years before
he was in the white house
he repeated the story after being told
that a week later
so about two months the guy's delusional
do you remember about two months ago out
of nowhere he was given a speech and he
announced that he had cancer and then
literally everybody was like he doesn't
have canister that's just the dementia
it's like that's
that that's the level that we're at he
should be more unpopular yeah there's
something going on I mean he should be
whatever whatever he should have the
highest the highest disapproval ratings
of any president I want to I want to go
to Tom Tom for you we've been friends uh
for 15 years you grew up you lived in
Florida Boca right around here you grew
up you've lived in Connecticut
California we've lived together in
California Texas and Florida we met in
California you've done very well in
business Silicon Valley you've been
professor at Biola pepper now you've
done all this stuff you're married you
got two kids your daughter's about to go
to school your wife is here with us when
you're looking out at all the things
that's going on right now okay for
yourself you got the santis you got
Newsome you got Trump
I want you to speak from the paranoid
side because you got a paranoid side as
a business person because we have to be
or else you'll go out of business from
the paranoid side what's keeping you up
at night saying this is my concern if
XYZ happens we could be in the same
situation as we were two and a half
years ago what are you thinking well I
feel like I'm watching you know Japanese
Kabuki theater play out you know with
the media and the things that they're
they're they're they're they're bouncing
right now it says you know I look at it
and I say wow isn't it sort of
coincidental that a very well versed
research group drops 500 pages of Oppo
research on the very day that the
indictment is finally dropped by a man
convinced by the Democratic party to
become a kamikaze pilot which is Brag
and I think that's basically what's
happened to us I think he's just
basically taking one for the team they
promising a book deal and that's what's
going to be right you're going to be out
of office you get a book deal just like
the Press secretaries do or you'll get a
show on MSNBC you're all going to be
good I look at it and I say wait a
minute what's going on that we see here
down below here this is a pretty
skillful game that's being played and it
bothers me and what it bothers me is
that we've lost the ability to
rationally debate one another over core
issues but protect the soil that we're
standing on that allows us to have free
speech and have that debate you know
that's my concern and what keeps me up
at night is like you know you're arguing
on a Podium that may be on fire and
you're both going to fall through if you
follow the the metaphor of course and
I'm like you know be careful what you
wish for and I I had you know I've had a
lot of liberal friends in California we
got along well we worked at the same
companies you know for five years you
know I had you know you know a gay boss
I didn't care you know was he a good
boss or not and we all got along there
was no Animas on oh you're this you're
this there wasn't like this a biting
line like I feel like today if I had
that if I flip back the clock to be 30
years old again and had the same
situation would there be this different
vibe that's going on between people and
I think there would be and I think it's
terrible and what keeps me up at night
is that I look at my girls I say what
platforms they're going to be tomorrow
to have rational discussions about
people with people about things that
matter and I think we need to have like
a strong leader rise up to be the
president who can basically pull people
together but do it from a period of from
a position of strength from a position
of poise from a position of leadership I
mean you one of the greatest you know
compliments people gave Reagan and I go
back on this is when they said that
other countries remember when they said
he's crazy what that meant was that they
were a little afraid of him and that
little afraid became respect because you
know what it's not that he might push
the button and blow up the whole World
with nukes but he was willing to take
you know Kaiser sose move then one move
that the other guy wouldn't and it kind
of keeps saying some balance or strong
leadership so it keeps me up is waiting
for strong leadership to emerge and
waiting for America to come back do you
think there's a chance that Biden or
Newsom gets uh uh in the White House in
2024 like is there a concern that one of
those two could be in the White House in
2012. yeah my concern is that what
they're doing here is inflaming a wing
of the GOP to give Trump enough juice to
win the primary because I think that
they are scared spitless of a moderate
candidate with potential like DeSantis
got it I think they're terrified of that
how many guys feel that way by the way
how many guys feel the way he's saying
right now really really okay very end by
the way just out of curiosity how many
of you guys don't have that concern Make
Some Noise if you're not so more have
that concern so on the same sentiments
as you interesting so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you